there is nothing more prestigious in cs
go than getting your own graffiti sure a
major title or an mvp award might seem
more important but those things fade in
time a graffiti though that lasts
forever valve adds in these monuments to
mark some of the most iconic plays to
ever happen at a cs go major and there
are currently six in the game right now
but what about cs go's other iconic
plays the ones that you and your friends
talk about the ones that make the hair
on the back of your neck stand up the
ones that made you fall in love with cs
go in the first place today we're going
to talk about the plays that deserve a
graffiti even if it didn't happen at a
major and before we get into that make
sure you're subscribed to the score
esports that way you'll never miss a
video just like this one and with that
let's get into the top 10 plays that
deserve a graffiti
starting us off at number 10 is rowdy
shroudy and the infamous shroud boost oh
my god huge play by shroud right there
the patience is there any doubt that
you're watching championship level
counter strike is shroud is known for
anything it's his crisp aim and insane
mechanics but nothing is more
representative of his 3 000 iq than his
a site boost on cash down 15 to 14 at
the sivo land finals the odds were
stacked against shroud and the rest of
cloud9 as they would try to push
overtime against eye by power with only
pistols in hand they played double
safety they had to they bought pistols
on the last round they didn't get
anything have we already crowned i buy
power or could the unthinkable eco round
wins save them and push them to overtime
i might flip the table over if that
happens so with a cz and a dream shroud
got a boost up onto boxes and proceeded
to play the waiting game 25 seconds left
if the clock runs out on them and they
give up over time it will be the
heartbreak of a generation
molotov's in set piece out shroud has
let them all pass
one two three
even though c9 went on to lose the game
this play led to the boost boxes
becoming lovingly renamed after shroud
but maybe valve can take it one step
further and commemorate shroud's
unbelievable trigger discipline with a
sick graffiti like this one
coming in hot at number nine is summit1g
and his infamous self-immolation oh my
god
there's that
oh summit
what's up reddit at 2016's austin
dreamhack open north american hopeful
splice found themselves up 15 to 11
against clg on train all summit had to
do to win the first map was pull off a
1v1 and defuse the bomb which he did
kind of and now it's summit in the 1v1
to try and close this out against bugley
buggy playing it aggressive we know that
is going to clutch it and splice will
close out map number one
16-11
oh wait
what
no
what happened
oh no summit
no
oh that is uh heartbreaking
[Applause]
yes summit tossed the molly to push out
and pick up the quick frag on fugly but
he walked through the fire and died on
his way to defusing the bomb
even worse splice went on to lose in
overtime and were eliminated from the
tournament after dropping the next map
cutler and tarik and now jdm goes for a
no-scope not gonna happen but it's davey
and freakazoid and they get three quick
kills down to a one on two and cutler
the apocalypse is going to end it
and with that said clg
was a heartbreaking upset coming in
summit had control of the map but
unfortunately that mistake cost him big
time and clg will steal it away
this moment has been immortalized by the
community and now whenever anyone has an
accident with a molotov the one g's show
up in chat now if only valve could put a
little reminder on b site so that no one
ever makes a careless and relatable
mistake like this ever again
piercing its way through sheet metal and
concrete to take our number eight spot
is body and his iconic wall bangs on
cash as if things couldn't go from bad
to worse that is play of the year just
put that in that is the epitome of this
game wallbangs are responsible for some
of the nuttiest plays in cs go and few
are as memorable as bodies cross map
wall banks against astralis at esl pro
league yeah of course yeah yeah but but
it was it was done when the risk was
done
that really just hit i wasn't really
looking away where's that gone that was
from
one
body figured out that if you shoot
through the garage towards z at one
minute and 49 seconds that there's a
strong possibility you'll connect on a
wall bang which happened not once but
twice still 10-2 like you said a
difficult round considering bobby's
trying it again
oh no
no way no way you can't possibly do that
twice in a row body's back-to-back wall
banks left everyone stunned and cash was
quickly patched so that no one could
replicate it oh this i like this we're
seeing it from the ct's pov you can just
see what's going through his mind before
my god a lot of fans thought this play
would be an instant graffiti but alas
valve still hasn't answered their calls
so we did
cutting its way into the seventh spot on
our list is kenny s desperation knife
kill on guardian
[Applause]
would you believe it
to go for that play and make it 5-3 navi
now it's not every day that you get to
see an era's best two awpers face off
against each other in a 1v1 but that's
exactly what happened during a
particularly chaotic round at esl one
cologne 2015. with the bomb planted
navy's guardian tried to aggressively
rush the site in an attempt to no scope
an unsuspecting kenny s what happened
next was one of the most insane
sequences in cs go history and now it's
all on guardian will you try and hold
the off he gets the shot onto apex is he
going to try and go huge here can he
hits on sight straight in his face
doesn't hit the nose go doesn't hit the
pistol oh
can he ask would you believe it the
balls on that
kenny s was able to dodge two of
guardians no scopes and when he couldn't
secure the pistol kill he decided to
just pull out his knife and leap a
guardian this ballsy desperation play is
firmly etched into the community's
collective memory now all valve needs to
do is properly honor it with a graffiti
like we did
coming in at number six is simple's
iconic throw on dust2 that is just him
styling on nitro that's him just
mentally breaking him saying i'm just
going to utterly dominate you in this
one-on-one every so often simple comes
around to show the world why he really
is the greatest player of all time and
few plays are as creative or as
memorable as the one he pulled off
against nitro at esl one new york right
outside smoke gonna go off simple on the
other side he pulls out the pistol he's
got the p250 close range it's a one shot
nitro he's got a triple he fakes it once
and just goes to check the window this
is all about timing nitro does have a
volume of another smoke so it could be
really rough for simple to actually get
through this he's gonna throw the awp oh
my god simple what is happening
what even is that now for those of you
who may be confused here it's a
semi-common trick for players to fake a
flashbang by tossing out their pistols
in the hopes of drawing attention away
from your opponent which is exactly what
simple did
kind of instead of distracting nitro
with a lowly pistol the cs go prodigy
elected to use his nearly five thousand
dollar orb as the distraction after this
play the fake oil flash became a
mainstay amongst the community but
unfortunately foul doesn't think it's
worthy of simple second graffiti
breaking into our top five now is hiko
and his inhuman reactions that is a
terrifying message to anyone who ever
dares to challenge hiko but surely that
is going to be a kill that will go down
in history
hiko has had an unbelievable career in
counter-strike but there are few plays
more jaw-dropping than the quick
reflexes he displayed at 2014's esl one
cologne hiko is going to go for it
fryeburg will eventually fall
but it is too late
garrett is going to be waiting hiko
charges in doesn't check what
oh my god inhuman reactions
hiko
after all these years heco's kill on get
right is still considered one of the
greatest shots in cs go history
unfortunately there isn't any in-game
nod to hiko's brilliant flick and we
wanted to bring attention to that gross
injustice
taking the fourth spot on our list is
snacks and his stunning 4k pistol clutch
i've never seen anything like it what
the hell was that
that's gonna be one of the sickest
pistol clutches i've ever seen in the
entirety of cs go snacks is an absolute
legend and the polish star has racked up
a number of memorable plays over the
years
but if there's one moment that deserves
a graffiti it's his insane 4k pistol
clutch from the esl new york finals
guardian does damage but it comes out
worse for where in the end neo gone
guardian wraps back around then it's
gonna be bialy down in the end to just
snacks does find one let's not leave him
out of this the big apple and snacks is
hungry he's got one kill already on the
usp
low hp as well on guardian and flame
he's trying to bait them out trying to
get them into one on ones as he dances
back and forth between the box what a
shot on deadpool oh guardian bye bye and
it's on the flamey he's tapped in flame
he's got a big
what in god's name is that from stacks
a flashy play is deserving of a graffiti
and there is nothing quite as flashy as
shutting down some of the world's
greatest players sadly for us kabul has
since been removed from the active pool
and reworked into oblivion but hopefully
one day we can see a return of kabul
with a much needed knot to the hungry
man himself
cracking the top three of our list is
happy and his incredibly iconic deagle
ace i think i just broke my chair i
might need a new one
a worthy sacrifice a chair for a round
that's going to go down in history
without a doubt here the deagle is one
of the most iconic and deadliest weapons
in counter-strike there are countless
legendary deagle plays and even a few
deagle aces but none of them come close
to what happy was able to pull off on
inferno at 2015 dreamhack open london
they aren't rushing this time around
they're taking their sweet time hoping
to catch somebody peak on envy's side
and well that's what happens when you go
around the corner happy with juan dig oh
and another one
oh the third
happy
he could get another one here too dupree
debris is like sweating bullets
he's gonna get the quad killing the ace
what is this
happy got four headshots and another
kill facing down the barrel of a p90 and
all he gave us was a smile and a couple
of high fives that play would help envy
win the map and later the tournament
which is why it's one of the most iconic
moments in cs go history amazing amazing
performers
i think we all know uh
what i want an explanation of straight
away dude what happened with that deagle
just digging
there is no doubt that if this happened
at a major there would be a graffiti
honoring happy unfortunately we'll just
have to speculate on what exactly that
would look like
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
none other than kadian and his epic
clutch that won esl pro league for for a
second in my life i made everyone who
was watching counter-strike hold their
breath and yeah that's something i'll
never forget kdm has had one of the most
tumultuous cs go careers over these last
few years but with the move to online
play and the solidification of heroic he
and the rest of his team have turned
into one of csgo's greatest success
stories but what truly makes a story
great is its ending and there are a few
endings as sweet as how cadian won esl
pro league for heroic gets the op and
kills the guy ct oh yeah ah yeah
oh oh my god he's knifed him and he's
gotten away with the orb i'm starting to
get nervous
there's no way there's no way kaden you
can't win pro league like this you can't
win pro league like this
no way
exile's left 40 seconds and the bombs on
a take your time son you're about to
make the play of your career he's
thinking about round two
gets the info he just has to hit this
shot and he's done it for heroic
the leader
calling well above his years clearly
you're an animal
starting with just a pistol and ending
with two hp kadian did the unthinkable
but since it wasn't at a major it will
never be commemorated as a graffiti
there are still some hopefuls out there
that think canadian will get his
memorial one day but to him the support
from his team and fans are more than
enough
taking the top spot for plays that
deserve a graffiti is stewie2k and his
famous b site hold at the boston major
this has to be one of the most
incredible story lines we've ever had
a north american team
in north america with a major win faze
and cloud9 found themselves facing off
in the finals of the 2018 boston major
and after trading maps back and forth
faze were up 15 to 11 and on
championship point cloud 9's hopes
seemed shot but c9 were able to claw
their way back to a 15-14 scoreline and
in the dying seconds of the 30th round
faze made a last-ditch rotation onto
b-site where stewie2k was alone and
armed with an orp what happened next was
history in the making but also automatic
is going towards saying nothing else is
going on he's got to go back stewie's on
his own but look at the time look at the
time there's seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more playing
stewie's walking around we're going to
overtime
tom's going to do
[Applause]
stewie single-handedly sent the game to
overtime and with the momentum and crowd
behind them c9 was able to push through
and win the major guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh it's happened
they made it work clown nine are your
e-league major champions
there are a few plays in cs go that have
had as big of an impact as this one with
this play stewie2k made north american
cs go history and it's a travesty the
valve never gave this man an in-game
tribute
well there you go that is our list now
come on valve look at those place look
at them how do none of them have a
graffiti yet you got to make it happen
look we've literally given you the
images make it happen are there any
players out there though that you think
should have made it onto our list let us
know also let us know what you want to
see next on the channel also a quick
shout out to one of our viewers stanley
calvin who sent in the idea for this
video to tips at the score.com if you
have a great idea for a top 10 or any
other video you want to see on the
channel make sure you send it in to our
email that's tips at the school.com
thanks for watching guys and i'll see
you all in the next one
make my day junior
flash oh bad flash secret one oh one
hell as well locker secret
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]